hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the cat that
got the milk okay now this is actually a
maze type abstract weirdy wonky funky
game so we're gonna play it has very
little to do about cats so from what
I've seen so the controls are up and
down up and down I thought this was a
maze game Oh Oh No are the drugs is how
did it kick in what what am I playing Oh
up up up okay that's that's harder than
I thought it was gonna be okay there's
actually also a challenging him so I got
a press up and like you got a press up
and let go when I need to
so this is actually this might not be as
easy as I had anticipated oh wow okay
yeah ah don't play this games if you
have any sensitivity to colors and weird
shapes and things go straight I think
I'm a cat I think that's me I think I'm
a cat over there and I'm guessing on
going through the city going through the
city yeah try get some escape oh lordy
how do I get through that I can't I
can't turn left I gotta make sure I get
it right on the fudge now there's it
mice
how am I supposed to do that oh my god
oh my god okay this may not seem hard to
you but it it's actually quite
challenging because you can only press
up and down to change your direction I
got this hang on maybe it's not as
challenging as I think it is yep Dada
yeah ah yes the sound out it will
increase what yes the sound effects hell
they do when you're playing this game on
your food okay thank you
did I miss my target I miss my target
it's tiny how am I supposed to be able
to hit that uh-huh fodder nodders ma
there uh-huh bars
yeah who's that Akio I'm gonna get it
I'm gonna get it
good fudge all right this is where
things get hard I guess yeah yeah
got ya got ya wait a minute how know how
the world am I supposed to get through
there I can't turn left
oh just like this like super easily like
that some to pro oh what the hell is
this what to be a city Oh God
hip hip but yeah yeah to pro for what
what the hell what's going on hey wait a
minute give me a chance here
stop trying it on my cat you son of a
[ __ ] I I swear ting mana mana this is
this this is this is harder than it
looks okay everybody get off my back and
you try for yourself is your show good
at video games oh my god not okay for
pride here we go yeah yeah yeah Oh first
try oh oh oh I'm gonna get through this
game motivation that was easy why not
that Super Meat Boy how much would you
get through there oh okay I see you me
for me
you me hey you didn't hop about I oh no
oh no oh no oh no wait I die okay yeah
go up left right that's a right go down
go to clubs if you would open up sooner
I would have been able to go that way
are you buddy
screw you buddy I'm guessing the last
few levels are just gonna be basically
impossible uh-huh how do I go laughs oh
well thank you for making it easier for
me I wasn't able to do that on my own
yep haha Oh
oh my god what Wow Oh what kind of cat
would go into here is this a metaphor
for trying to avoid predators you know a
cat's natural predators
giant grinding teeth in the middle of a
city
in the middle of the set I Hey
gotta get a sigh Hodge how am i his
complete friggin bull nah got it Oh what
the hell was that
ah not enough time Hey ah ah yeah oh
[ __ ] me buddy ha ha ha yeah
oh so close I was so close come on come
on come on go yeah oh my god
Oh Oh what is this what is this supposed
to be what is all of this what is this
ball that's what this is it's let me
through
no incident thank you thank you last
level oh my god what is this the boss
level what is that
what is all of that hey what is all that
that's bull gonna throw anything like
that at me before okay I'm getting
through good I can't turn is it is that
supposed to be the exit over there
that's circle on the ground how much am
i dead I can't even tell if I died he
freakin squares and shapes just run
through everywhere this is impossible
this is impossible
this is friggin impossible here good how
am I supposed to be able to go there is
oh this is oh this is oh this is this is
ridiculous
am I still alive I think I'm up yeah
once I get to that part I can't get
through there it's impossible this is
impossible this is the definition of
impossible because I can't pass it pase
I can't bhasayate I can't do say it
no it's different I'm a I'm a kitty cat
I'm just I for poussey you know
fluffy okay never know those jokes I'm
too highbrow for that time
and I'm gonna get through here cuz Oh
mother Harper this is impossible to get
over there I can't get through those
Wiggly Wagle horizontal ones I don't
want to skip the level shut up I've made
it through every other one of your
stupid-ass levels I'm gonna make it
through this one ah here's a badge you
barely see where I am in comparison to
all the noise that's going around me I
can't go backwards so I got to go
through it I gotta go for all maybe I
don't know maybe I gotta get to that
point
oh my god I'm gonna stab my eyes out
with needles all of these needles go
into my eyeballs right now I need it
they practically are going into my
eyeballs this cat milk is not worth it
kitty cat kitty the cat is not worth the
milk the milk is not worth the cat I'm
going crazy goes I go
Tiger bonkers there go bonkers crazy
you're good there's secret passage that
I'm not seeing they're just some super
ultra mega stupid ah
oh my god this is [ __ ] blow I'm in
alunite we're am I'm gonna lose my
breath
goodbye baby I love that baby do me
right bye
um how [ __ ] that this is a boss level
Oh not gonna get ha ha yeah I didn't
take 26 minutes I took like eight what
are you talking about oh well done the
cat has his milk he will sleep well for
another day you mean he's got do that
again another day kitty cat that was not
worth it
who's not worth the milk you should have
not gone for that milk that was Nicholas
kitty cat I'm sorry for your loss man
that was a waste of time I just got to
say that that was a big waste of time
right there sorry to say you've wasted
up way more than the nine lives you had
to get that milk Oh anyway that's all I
have for now thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for vid
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
hahaha
Oh
uhh